So it's very quickly getting very real in
the impeachment inquiry against Donald Trump.
This is starting to now I'll
get into, people are going to have to show
up, people are going to have to provide documents
or maybe face the consequences of not doing
so.
Although it's not totally clear in this administration
if there will be ever consequences for ignoring
subpoenas and the latest person subpoenaed
as Rudy Donald Trump's personal lawyer, Rudy
Giuliani, who has been subpoenaed by the house
intelligence committee to provide a number
of different documents and Rudy of course,
is one of the sort of top people who's been
involved in this campaign to pressure Ukraine
into helping Donald Trump in 2020 by investigating,
which is of course of course code for investigate
and determine that you as a result of that
investigation need to say negative things
about Joe Biden.
The letter to Rudy Giuliani identifies him
as an agent of Trump in the scheme to advance
Trump's interests through abuses of power
and they want documents from Rudy and I don't
know that they're going to get documents from
Rudy.
This is an administration that has gotten
away with simply ignoring subpoenas and subpoena
power, although not uncontroversial.
I mean, listen, there are reasonable debates
you can have about edge cases or blurry area
cases with regard to subpoena power.
Can subpoena power be abused, you know, with
any mechanism.
There are debates to be had, but this is an
administration that has just directly and,
and unabashedly flouted a subpoena power,
ignoring all sorts of requests for everything
from Donald Trump business records that could
be tied to a mall, humans clause violations
or potential money laundering all the way
up through and including requests, subpoena
requests for, um, witnesses to show up and
talk about possible crimes that they have
witnessed.
So I hope that subpoenas that are apart of
an impeachment inquiry will not be allowed
to be ignored.
But I don't know the answer to that because
the precedent under this administration has
been that they just ignore them and then there
are no consequences.
Now we've also learned in the last 24 hours
that the secretary of state, Mike Palm PEO
was also listening in on live on that phone
call on July 25th between Donald Trump and
the Ukrainian president.
We didn't previously know that prior to, you
know, 12 or 16 hours ago and Palm PEO himself
is becoming a bigger and bigger part of this
entire impeachment inquiry.
And what we are seeing if we zoom out a little
bit, is that this is growing into one of the
most sort of all encompassing political scandals
for an administration and a long time.
And I think that it actually is informative
to compare and contrast to the impeachment
of bill Clinton because a lot of people on
the ripe love to bring up bill Clinton in
the context of Trump's wrongdoing and impeachment
as they look.
Clinton got impeached.
Uh, let's go back to bill Clinton's impeachment.
Bill Clinton was impeached for lying about
an affair.
Bill Clinton cooperated.
Bill Clinton did not attempt to tamper with
witnesses.
He didn't attempt to obstruct the process
of investigation.
He didn't ignore subpoenas.
His attorney wasn't part of the scandal.
His secretary of state wasn't part of the
scandal.
His attorney general wasn't part of the scandal
and this is one of the major differences here
that we see with what's happening with Donald
Trump.
It's not just Trump did a thing.
First of all, the thing Trump did is really
bad.
It's way worse than lying about an affair.
It's pressuring.
Pressuring is not even a heavy enough word,
but it's extorting a foreign power to smear
a possible election opponent.
That's number one, but Trump's lawyer, former
New York city mayor Rudy Giuliani is involved.
His attorney general William Barr is involved.
His secretary of state, Mike Palm PEO is involved
documents related to the incident.
In this case, a full transcript of the phone
call on July 25th with the Ukrainian president
has been moved from the place where it would
normally be kept to some other place in order
to obscure and obfuscate.
So anyone even remotely comparing this to
the Clinton impeachment.
I welcome that comparison.
If you think that there's anything similar
about the two situations, you don't understand
the facts or you're deliberately ignoring
them, but that then gets us to the real sort
of important pressing question, which is what
does happen if Rudy Giuliani ignores the subpoena?
Can you imagine that?
I mean, just think back to the immediately
post nine 11 days.
At one point, Rudy Giuliani was a widely respected
politician in the United States, even by many
Democrats.
Now I want to be very clear.
Uh, many of those Democrats disagreed with
the policies of Rudy Giuliani in New York
city, for example, broken windows, policing
and so on.
But in a very general sense, to the extent
that you see bi-partisan, not support, but
at least recognition that someone is a good
faith actor.
Rudy Giuliani was one of those people for
a period of time in the United States.
Then he became mayor nine 11 where any question
he was asked politically was, you remember
I was mayor during nine 11.
Right?
And now he has become Trump's hatchet man
involved in who knows how many possible crimes
involved as maybe the most irrational, reflexive
defender of anything that Donald Trump does
or says always all the time.
And there's some sad element to it.
I read some commentaries online saying it's
actually sad what's happened to Rudy Giuliani.
Uh, he chose us.
He chose this.
So I don't feel bad for the guy, but it is
interesting to look at just how far he has
fallen from being a, a man, an American political
character that at one point at least had the
respect, if not support of people on the other
side of the political aisle.
We will see what happens as far as the Rudy
Rudy Giuliani subpoena.